everyone knows that triangles have three
sides but what the shirt in our fall
curiosity box presupposes
is
what if they don't
the midpoint of each of a triangle's
sides the foot of each of its altitudes
and the midpoint between its orthocenter
and each of its vertices all fall on the
circumference of a circle a triangle's
in circle is the largest circle that
fits inside it and its circum circle is
the circle on which all of its vertices
lie
now relative to these three circles the
sides can be described they each have
end points on the circum circle
midpoints on the nine point circle and
are tangent to the in circle but in 1993
bf sherman discovered that there are not
three lines with these properties there
are four
and our shirt celebrates it this orange
line is the fourth side of this triangle